the nearest thing that the new york
times had to a writer
hired to be a sort of kind of centrist
conservative liberal after the 2016
election
after the new york times completely
botched it has resigned from the new
york times
that's it couldn't take it a letter
from barry weiss barry weiss writes it
is with sadness that i write to tell you
i am resigning from the new york times
the paper's failure to anticipate
the outcome of the 2016 election meant
that it didn't have a firm grasp
of the country that it covers so she
details
why and how she was hired i'm going to
skip around a little bit to just
the juiciest lines a new consensus has
emerged in the press
but perhaps especially at this paper the
truth isn't a process of collective
discovery
but an orthodoxy already known to an
enlightened few
whose job is to inform everyone else
couldn't be truer twitter is not on the
masthead of the new york times
but twitter has become its ultimate
editor i always
was always taught the journalists were
charged with writing the first rough
draft of history
now history itself is one more
ephemeral thing molded to fit the needs
of a predetermined narrative
there are terms for this unlawful
discrimination
hostile work environment and
constructive discharge i'm no legal
expert
but i know that this is wrong
this is a new mccarthyism
ideas cannot win on their own they need
a voice
they need a hearing above all they must
be
backed by people willing to live by them
that opinion is no longer welcome at the
new york times that opinion
is no longer welcome at our chief
institutions
in this country the things that we
believe the truths that we cherish and
hold dear
have been rooted out of the institutions
how much time left do we have to save
the edifice we'll get into it
i'm michael knowles and this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show i asked
yesterday
what should the new name of the
washington
redskins b and i got an answer i'd never
heard it before but it's
absolutely brilliant what we need to do
is keep the name redskins
and change the logo to a potato
seems so obvious how did it not occur to
us
before nothing resembling
the old school liberals is left
when i say the old school liberals i'm
talking about you know we call them the
classical liberals or the libertarians
but i'm even talking about the old
school progressive liberals people like
barry weiss
at the new york times which was a
liberal paper we always knew it was a
liberal paper i never liked the new york
times
but at least the new york times would
occasionally listen to ideas that it
didn't agree with
occasionally the new york times would
try to understand why it got things
wrong
that's over that is gone
and now when you hold those liberal
ideas
those more old-school progressive ideas
there's only one place for you to go
and that is to the right we've seen this
it's not just barry weiss's letter
there was a letter from it's now called
the letter
from harper's where a bunch of old
school liberals said we've got to defend
our liberal values
they want to have this middle ground
between the right wing the
the traditionalists the populists the
trump people and
the hard left and it isn't working
there's no space there
one has got to pick a side even basic
values
that we would all we all used to agree
with we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal
endowed by their creator with certain
unalienable rights that was as
near to an unassailable truth within the
american regime as we
had even that completely under attack
and it's not under attack by the way
by the white supremacist neo-nazi ku
klux klan
of whom there are what seven people left
in the country
it's not it's under attack by the woke
left
by these liberal institutions that have
totally lost whatever
identity they once had they've given it
all over to the woke left
this seems nowhere clearer than in a
recent broadcast by nick cannon do you
remember nick cannon
nick cannon is an actor he's a
musician sort of he's been a
pop culture figure for decades at this
point
nick cannon decided to broadcast
yesterday
not on even his radical left
ideology you know like when we think of
marxism or something now is something
like that
he broadcast on a radical left racial
ideology
the the mirror image of the nazi kkk ku
klux klan you know the thing the left is
always talking about we got to get rid
of racism we need anti-racism well it
turns out their anti-racism
so often is just the mirror image just
as bad
only directed against the other guy nick
cannon preached about
the power of melanin
let's go to what it really is then when
we talk about the power of melanated
people
when we talk about who we really are as
guys and understanding that
our melanin is so power and it connects
us in a way
that the reason why they fear black the
reason why they fear is because they
the lack that they have of it so then
when you see
what you know dr uh francis c wellesley
talked about
is that fear in that that that genetic
annihilation efficiency
when you have a person that has has the
lack of pigment the lack of melon right
that they know that they will be
annihilated so therefore however they
got the power
they they they have the lack of
compassion
that melanin comes with compassion
melanin comes with soul that we call it
we call it soul we
soul brothers and sisters that's the
melon in that connection so the people
that don't have it
have are are a lit and i'm gonna say
this carefully
are a little less and
and and where the term actually comes
from because i'm bringing it all the way
back around okay
to minister fair okay there we go now my
eyes go up this is minister farrakhan
uh farrakhan louis farrakhan is
a a complete degenerate he's a
black racial identitarian he espouses
uh horrifically heretical views on
religion
and his religion is grounded primarily
in race we've heard this kind of thing
before
you remember when uh nicholas sandman
that covington kid
who who was going down to the pro-life
rally with his catholic high school and
he was just standing on the national
mall
minding his own business he had a hat
said make america great again hat that
is promoted by the president of the
united states
and this group of kids was heckled by a
group of black supremacists
called the hebrew israelites and they
were screaming all sorts of terrible
things at him and then that
crazy native american dude walked up to
him and started banging a drum in his
face kid behaved very well and was
destroyed in the press and by the
present he's won a lot of judgments
against them
we've heard this sort of thing before
from
people we would call cultural marxists
in the academy
there there was one uh professor
jeffries this was
decades ago who had a theory of the sun
people and the ice people
the sun people were black people who got
you know all the nice warm rays of the
sun and the ice people those were white
people
they were less than as as nick cannon is
saying now i being sicilian i think i
get a nice little middle ground here
a little more melaninated but
this is a patently absurd theory isn't
it
and it's it's merely used uh you know
without any basis in science or history
it is used as a way to put down a group
of people on the basis of their race
we always hear about people being put
down on the basis of their race if they
are people of color but what nick cannon
is doing
is putting down white people on the
basis of their races saying they're less
than they don't have a soul
he says that they're savages
they had to be savages they had to be
barbaric
they had because they're in these nordic
mountains they're in these
rough uh torrential environments
so they they're acting as animals right
so they're the ones that are
actually closer to animals they're
closer to animals okay this is the kind
of stuff we can
expect from nick cannon now it's one
thing when you hear some wacko like
louis farrakhan say this it's another
thing when you're some wacko like nick
cannon say this
but the kind of stuff that these guys
are saying
is not just heard from these kooky guys
in the culture
or even a professor like lionel jeffries
talks about the sun people and the ice
people this kind of stuff is being heard
at newspapers like the new york times
where we see we've seen multiple
articles about abolishing whiteness the
problems of
whiteness this has now infiltrated the
mainstream left what used to be called
the mainstream liberal left and what's
so outrageous
is nick cannon just got he just lost his
job
for making these remarks but he didn't
he didn't lose his job for making these
remarks about the white people about
whom he made these marks
we will get to all of that in one second
first though i've got to thank our
friends over
at lifelock you know criminals do not
care
uh what is going on they will still
steal
your information they won't say oh you
know what we're in the midst of a tough
time here economically
they're going to steal your information
regardless okay fraudsters love
turbulent times cyber security
researchers
are warning that cyber criminals are
sending emails that include
black lives matter in the subject line
in an effort to install
malware on victims computers if any
curious party clicks on the file
attached to the email what happens
it installs a dangerous microsoft
windows malware known as trickbot
you think they would have had a more
subtle title for that trickbot anyway
very important to protect your
information and be responsible lifelock
detects a wide range of identity threats
like your social security number
for sale on the dark web and if they
find that your information maybe has
been compromised
they will send you an alert no one can
prevent all identity theft or monitor
all transactions at all businesses
lifelock can see threats that you might
miss on your own join now save up to 25
percent
off your first year these are the guys
that i trust go to lifelock
dot com slash knowles wlas that is
lifelock
dot com slash knowles k-w-l-e-s for
25 percent off nick cannon did get fired
i guess he had a contract with viacom
cbs and he did get fired here
here's the statement that viacom cbs
sent out vicom cbs condemns bigotry of
any kind and we categorically denounce
all forms of anti-semitism
we have spoken with nick cannon about an
episode of his podcast
canon's class on youtube which promoted
hateful speech and spread anti-semitic
conspiracy theories
because part of this video is he he
spreads this theory
also spread by the hebrew israelites and
other black supremacist groups
that the that black people american
blacks
are the true hebrews the israelites the
jews of the bible
and that the jews who we all know as
jews they're like the fake
jews or something like that what's so
striking to me about this statement from
vicom cbs
it only it only condemns in specific
terms
bigotry against jews but all the
bigotry that we just heard in that
video was against white people
generally he's talking about what but
that's okay
viacom doesn't condemn that bigotry that
bigotry is perfectly fine in fact in
many quarters
of the popular culture it's encouraged
which is why you hear these calls to
abolish whiteness you hear things like
toxic whiteness
you see city governments now forcing
their employees to go through mandatory
re-education programs
where they can learn about their
terrible whiteness and how they're
racist and they've got to
they've got to get rid of all of their
white privilege it's not just
in the world of media or in politics
it's also affected even the world of
fine art a
modern art museum curator has been fired
you probably do not follow the modern
art world terribly closely
i do not myself however one of the most
prominent curators in the country a guy
named
gary garros has just resigned
amid amid an uproar you wouldn't say he
resigned really
he was pushed out at the san francisco
museum of modern art
why was he pushed out why was he fired
why were there so many calls for him to
be fired
there were many calls for him to be
fired because this guy
gary garros suggested that he would not
completely stop buying artwork
from white male artists
he didn't say he was going to prefer
white male artists even
he said he was just not going to totally
stop
buying the artwork that was too much
he was confronted at an all staff zoom
meeting about this because now no one
holds meetings
in person and he was referred to
as a white supremacist he said this is
his exact words don't worry
we'll definitely still continue to
collect white artists
but they were going to focus now on
collecting artists of color
right so he's actually saying i'm going
to i'm going to
i'm going to disadvantage white artists
but we'll still we'll still be
collecting them
after that there was a petition
calling for his resignation that was
signed by 180 people
all because he didn't want to completely
cut out white guys
and he said that that in itself would be
reverse rate uh reverse racism
reverse discrimination which is
obviously true the petition said quote
gary's removal from the san francisco
museum of modern art is non-negotiable
considering his lengthy tenure at this
institution we ask
just how long have his toxic white
supremacist
beliefs regarding race and equity
directed his position curating
the content in the of the museum so if
you don't want to just
completely cancel white people from all
sectors of society
you're a toxic white supremacist and you
know what carols did because look he's
the curator of a modern art museum
something tells me the guy is not
exactly a rock ribbed
trump supporter or something he's not a
berkey and conservative or something
like that
he said i want to offer my personal
and sincere apology to every one of you
i realized almost as soon as i used the
term reverse discrimination that this is
an offensive term
and was an extremely poor choice of
words on my part i'm very sorry
at how upsetting these words were to
many people on the staff
so he's out that the rule is now if you
don't think
that white people should be completely
removed from all aspects of society
you you will lose your job you will be
smeared as a white supremacist
you will have to make a very public
apology and
you will lose your career anyway
meanwhile
all these people who pretend to be
talking for racial justice or black
lives matter
has their record on racial issues these
people who are pushing
to quote gary correctly reverse
discrimination reverse racism
how's their record on protecting black
lives not very good
a one-year-old baby was killed in new
york
city over the past few days one-year-old
baby devel
gardner jr one-year-old black baby in
new york
he was not killed by police brutality
was not killed by white supremacists or
the ku klux klan or neo-nazis
he was killed in a mostly black
neighborhood
presumably by black people and not cops
either
so this is the view held by the baby's
family
the baby's family is speaking out
specifically his grandmother
for the cowards that did this
you should be ashamed of yourself
because
everybody talk about black lives matter
what about baby lives what about
teenager lives
like you took an innocent child from a
mother and a father
as well as the grandparents and i don't
think it's fair
doesn't seem fair at all and there are
local people in that community who are
speaking out
explicitly against this against the
racial narrative that is being pushed
by the left a horrific story
one-year-old baby
the mainstream media ignore innocent
babies getting killed what do they do
they focus on criminals who get killed
and by the way
i'm not even talking about criminals who
are killed in officer-involved killings
i'm not i'm not talking about those rare
cases
that have been the ostensible
cause of all the riots and protests even
though i think really
those are just incidents that have been
exploited by people with a radical left
political agenda but i'm not
even talking about that i'm talking
about actual
100 convicted criminals like the worst
people on earth
who then get the death penalty the left
sheds tear upon tear for them
one year old baby killed in his
neighborhood can't talk about that story
that's going to get memory hold
but brutal brutal killers
on death row we shed tears for them
completely
backwards we will get to the first
federal execution
in decades in the united states which
just took place yesterday first though
i've got to thank our friends over at
ring
speaking of violence and protecting
yourself from violence
and protecting yourself from people who
want to take your stuff
very important these days ring is on
admission to make neighborhoods safer
their home security products are
designed to give you peace of mind
around the clock
ring gives you protection at every
corner the video doorbells let you
answer the door and check in on your
home
anytime you keep an eye on your doorstep
you can speak to delivery people when
you can't come to the door that's
whether you're in your bedroom whether
you're at the office whether you're on a
beach
whether that visitor is someone who
means to do you harm whether that
visitor is a delivery man
whether that visitor is your
mother-in-law maybe who means to do you
harm you can speak to them right from
your phone smart lighting brightens up
blind spots
makes sure that you always come home to
a brightly lit
house full home security systems give
you everything you need to protect your
family pets and property i love this
thing
i give this out to my friends as a
housewarming gift i've mentioned this
several times they all love it and the
thing that i really like about it one
it's cool it makes you feel like you're
living in the future
and also it's inexpensive so i get
credit for a great gift but i don't have
to spend a lot of money
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kit when you go to ring.com
knowles that includes the ring video
doorbell 3 and shine pro it's all you
need to start building custom security
for your home today
ring.com knowles ring.com
knowles federal government for the first
time
in almost 20 years
executed an inmate for
a capital offense this is good news
it's a good thing when justice is done
and yet
according to many people on the left and
frankly even some people on the right
this couldn't be worse so terrible such
a sad story
the criminal who was executed is daniel
lewis
lee he was convicted on may 4th 1999
of killing three members of an arkansas
family william frederick muller
his wife nancy ann and his
eight-year-old
step-daughter sarah elizabeth powell
this guy this guy that everyone is
weeping tears over the radical left is
weeping tears over
daniel lewis lee was a member of a white
supremacist organization an
actual white supremacist organization
not not in the way that the left smears
modern museum art gallery curators or
frankly anyone to the right of hillary
clinton's white supremacists
this guy was the real deal he robbed and
then shot this family including the kid
with a stun gun
duct taped plastic bags around their
heads this is a stun gun don't forget so
he didn't kill them when he attacked
them
duct taped plastic bags around their
heads weighed down each victim with
rocks
and drowned the family in the bayou
so this guy all these years later
20 years later got what he deserved
and the left is furious rolling stone
magazine referred to this as
state-sanctioned murder
because the guy got now first of all
the death penalty is a good thing it is
good that the civil authority has the
right
to commit the death penalty to execute
criminals
a lot of people just focus on the
deterrent factor of criminal justice so
they'll say well the death penalty
doesn't really deter crime
frankly i think it probably does deter
crime but you're right as it is
enacted and enforced right now its
deterrent effect is probably weak
because very few people
who receive the death penalty actually
have to deal with it
they'll be convicted they'll be
sentenced to the death penalty but very
often they'll get off
so it doesn't have a great deterrent
effect perhaps because it's not actually
used to deter people the rehabilitative
aspect of crime people focus on
they say the whole purpose of the
criminal justice system is just to make
people better reform people and the
death penalty doesn't do that so we got
to get rid of it first of all i think it
does reform people
i think to quote dr johnson hanging
concentrates the mind
when you know that you're about to be
hanged or electrocuted
or just executed by any manner by the
state it focuses your mind wonderfully
not on kind of temporal concerns
but on the eternal question so i think
even from a medicinal standpoint
death penalty has something to say for
it but then most importantly the thing
that everyone forgets
is justice the primary purpose of
criminal justice
is to punish people for committing
crimes for committing
acts of injustice it is retributive
that's not some people think that's
terrible that's a horrible idea or that
it's
that's just a secondary feature of the
system no that's the primary one
if if the criminal justice system were
just about rehabilitation then
there's no reason to require that
someone commit a crime to get into the
system
we could all use a little rehabilitation
we've all got really nasty habits that
we could have fixed
if the purpose were merely deterrent
same thing you wouldn't necessarily need
to commit a crime to do it
as long as we make an example of
somebody that could have a deterrent
effect
the the reason it's the criminal justice
system is you need to commit a crime to
do it
so you receive retribution for that and
that is what happens when we exact
justice just consider how backwards that
is
even beyond the idea that we kill a
million innocent babies a year
but we we ring our you know we clutch
our pearls and we rend our garments
when we kill one torturing psychopath
murderer
who kills an eight-year-old but forget
that
we've just had this whole black lives
matter movement we've just had this
whole remember that
we're setting the cities on fire and
tearing down statues and
it's the most important protest in the
country and yet when innocent black
lives are killed
blm is nowhere to be found and yet those
same radical leftists
who support organizations like blm cry
over these crazy white supremacists
ironically
these killers that's a backwards sort of
priorities think about this
we just saw this in st louis if you
walk up to somebody who's on their own
property
and you wave a gun in their face and you
threaten them and you say i'm coming for
you i'm gonna get you
that's fine you're a peaceful protester
as long as you have the right politics
but if you are the property owner whose
life and whose family's life and whose
property is being threatened
and you take out a gun and you say i'm
going to use this if you try to get me
that could be a crime the mccloskeys i
spoke to mark mccloskey who played part
of that interview yesterday
the mccloskeys is the guy in the pink
polo shirt and the white chinos who
defended their lives
and property in st louis they expect to
be
indicted that's the rumor going around
st louis there's already been a search
by the police of their home their
weapons have been confiscated
it seems like only a matter of time and
everyone is cheering this on
fortunately the president of the united
states
can see through this absurdity can see
this injustice he just came out and
defended the mccloskeys
and when you look at st louis with two
people that came out they were going to
be
beat up badly if they were lucky okay
if they were lucky they were going to be
beat up badly and the house was going to
be totally ransacked and probably burned
down like they tried to burn down
churches
and these people were standing there
never used it and they were legal
the weapons and now i understand
somebody local they want to prosecute
these people
it's a disgrace it is a disgrace
absolutely is and it's a great use by
the president of the bully pulpit
to try to inject a little bit of common
sense in here
and it's very interesting i guess sign
of the times you're living in
it's very interesting what president
trump will defend and what he will not
defend because i thought
when i saw trump come out and and defend
the mccloskeys i thought this is it
this guy totally gets it we talked
yesterday on the show
about how these seemingly trivial issues
oh this little family
in st louis oh this statue of george
washington or christopher columbus
who cares it's just a little issue it's
no big deal we got to talk about stuff
of national importance you know like tax
rates or something
so it doesn't matter and what president
trump realizes
is what the character of the queen's
private secretary
understands in the crown the tv show
which is that it's in the small things
that the rot begins it's in these
seemingly trivial cultural matters
little little in story about a family in
st
louis that the rot begins and president
trump has a
laser focus on that sort of stuff and
yet at the same time
as he's talking about that the trump
administration
is reversing course on what i thought
was a tremendously
popular policy it was a way to
pressure schools as we're trying to get
the schools to reopen which they
absolutely should
the only reason the schools are going to
remain shut down is for political
purposes
to make it easier for joe biden to hide
out in his basement for the next three
months
and then hopefully get elected president
without having to put his foot in his
mouth every single day on the campaign
trail that's what the democrats are
thinking
so the trump administration trying to
pressure schools one way they were doing
that
is they were saying okay if you're here
on a student visa you're here to study
at an american university
but now that university campus won't
open up and you're going to do online
learning
you have to go back to your country as
we said made perfect sense
it's a brilliant policy now
people derided this they said oh it's
terrible you're sending these poor
students back home
yes of course we are the reason that
they are here in the united states is to
study
if they can do it online if the left
wants to push that ridiculous policy
for its own political reasons by the way
that's fine but they have to deal with
the consequences of that then and the
consequences of that
are that these students that they love
welcoming into the country
have to go home because there's no
reason for them to be in the united
states now
if those students want to come into the
united states by another means they want
to get a work visa
or however else they can get here
they're free to do that they can apply
for that kind of visa
but you don't get to have your cake and
eat it too you don't get all the
benefits
without any of the costs that are being
pushed because the left
has an agenda come come november so
unfortunately
the trump administration has backed off
of this they've they've withdrawn this
proposed rule
that would have forced the the foreign
students to go back home if their
colleges weren't opening in the fall
i don't know who's advising trump on
this but it's bad stuff
you can see it in real time
you can see this happening this this tug
of war going on in the administration
i don't talk to that many people in the
administration
and yet so it's not like i'm telling you
tales at a school here from gossip that
somebody called me about
but you can just see it play out in real
time because there will be an official
statement from the white house on one
thing and then
president trump will undercut it in a
tweet he'll usually give the more
correct view in the tweet usually not
all the time
but but more times than than not
and then the policy will back off
there's a tug of war trump should listen
to his gut he should listen to the
conservatives in the administration
whoever is going weak whoever is going
squishy
as we're getting closer to november is
is not giving him good advice
but it's so interesting what he'll
defend what he won't defend when it's
him or when it
when the policy has been formed by some
committee of squishes who
were born and bred and raised in the
swampland of washington d.c because
president trump recognizes
even on issues that peop no one really
wants to defend
how important the symbolism in the
culture is even on an issue so unpopular
as
the confederate flag we will get into
that
we will get into how widespread the
radical rot on the left goes it's not
just confined
to nick cannon and to the new york times
even it goes all the way up to their
presidential
nominee first though i've got to thank
you i've got to thank you for
subscribing to the michael knowles show
on apple podcasts
and the michael knowles show on youtube
you have made my youtube channel
bigger than andrew clavin's this is the
most important thing that's the most
important thing to do so thank you very
much
i very much intend to to bug
drew about that uh be sure also to check
out the exclusive content that we've
posted on that youtube channel with guys
such as mark mccloskey
and recently donald trump jr also
ben shapiro our very own has a new book
it's called how to destroy america in
three easy steps
when he wrote this book he foresaw what
is happening
right now pretty crazy he's just got
like a crystal ball or something like
that
the book goes on sale tuesday july 31st
at 6 pm eastern 3 p.m pacific then we'll
be doing a virtual live signing event
on the day of release and with your
purchase of a signed copy you can write
in a question which
may be read and answered as he signs
your book live on the air you can
pre-order your signed copy and write in
your question at dailywire.com
ben go get it we'll be back with a whole
lot more
so president trump he
is backed off this policy which i think
is a mistake but then when it gets to an
issue that would be
far dicey or far more divisive an issue
like the confederate flag
president trump realizes the importance
of not giving an
inch to the woke mob president trump
back in 2015
you said the confederate battle flag
belongs in a museum do you still believe
that
all i say is freedom of speech it's very
simple my attitude is freedom of speech
very strong views on the confederate
flag with me it's freedom of speech very
simple
like it don't like it it's freedom of
speech would you be comfortable with
your supporters displaying the
confederate battle flag
you know it depends on what your
definition is but i am comfortable with
freedom of speech it's very simple you
understand why the flag
is a painful symbol for many people
because it's a reminder of slavery well
people love it and i don't view
i know people that like the confederate
flag and they're not thinking about
slavery
i look at nascar you go to nesco you had
those flags all over the place they
stopped
it i just think it's freedom of speech
whether it's
confederate flags or black lives matter
or anything else you want to talk about
it's freedom of speech i love how many
times he said freedom of speech because
president trump we talk about how you
know he's got no message discipline
he's all over the place this guy has
been in the public eye
since the late 1970s he was at the top
of network reality tv for 15 years
the guy knows how to communicate a
message in public i know that everyone
every
armchair critic in america now thinks
that they're a much better
rhetorician and orator than donald trump
but they're not
the guy actually does know how to
communicate and he realizes
that race is this incredibly touchy
divisive
issue there is great power to melanin
to uh to quote nick cannon he's right
there is a lot there's great power of
melanin here
because the left knows that if they can
in any way
tie in any any piece of our history any
piece of our culture
with the issue of race and and smear it
with the idea of
racism then they can get rid of it
they'll begin with the confederate flag
because a few people want to defend the
confederacy
my family george cobb knowles died at
the battle of boynton plank road
fighting for the union
what do i care about the confederacy
well i care i care about our history
and i care about people who want to
totally overturn american history and
the arguments that they're making to
overturn the confederate flag and to
tear it down
are arguments that they will make to
tear down the regular old
american flag by the way they're already
doing it colin kaepernick already did it
with the star spangled banner
and frankly with the betsy ross flag the
original american revolution flag
the same exact arguments it goes this
way back
president trump now three years ago
predicted it would happen he said
you're talking about robert e lee right
now you're talking about tearing down
his statues
but very soon for you're going to be
tearing down thomas jefferson and george
washington for the same reason
and it's already happening that's
already happening today that is
the power of melanin the power of these
people constantly trying to poke
the race issue that reporter yeah but
isn't it offensive
a white reporter by the way isn't it
offensive people are very offended trump
goes
yeah some i don't think people are
offended i think people like it it's not
about slavery freedom of speech
freedom of speech freedom of speech
there is not going to be
a nice civil dialogue about this
over the next three months at least
that's what the barry weissler's about
that's what people even the even the
liberals who are not totally radical
left
who are leaving these institutions
that's what they're showing you that's
what the harpers letter is about
these people who say there's we can't do
it we can't do it anymore there is no
place for us
this is a brutal ideological battle
and we can't give an inch trump seems to
know that
at least when he's following his best
instincts this thing goes
really really deep it's not just
laughing at a few professors or some
stupid new york times even
it goes really much deeper than that
it's all about november hillary clinton
unbelievably because irony is dead
appeared on trevor noah's
show on the daily show which i think is
about to get many more viewers than it
ever gets on the actual show because
we're gonna play it on our show i don't
know anyone who actually watches the
daily show anymore
but conservatives can at least talk
about the clip she goes
on the daily show and she fears that if
president trump
loses in november he won't accept the
results of that election does that sound
like anybody you know
i think it is um a fair point to raise
as to whether or not if he loses
he's going to go quietly or not uh and
we have to be ready for that
that's a real word could you imagine if
a presidential candidate lost the race
fair and square and then pretended that
it was illegitimate for
now going on four years and if her
supporters in the administrative
government
decided to launch completely fraudulent
investigations
of that winner of the election and spy
on that winner of the election and
totally hamper
that winner's presidency and tried i
guess i could go on and on
i think it rings a bell hillary if only
she had a mirror if only she could see
her own reflection
in the camera that she was speaking into
now hillary
is going to be embittered for a very
long time she was
the failed democratic nominee for
president
well it's 2020 it's four years later we
have a presumptive democratic nominee
now
joe biden does the radic the radicalism
couldn't touch old joe could it old joe
we've known joe
biden for 50 years in politics he's a
moderate
he's just regular old old uncle joe and
he's so
so lovable he'll he'll be fine he won't
sell out to the radical left well
some of the most prominent radical
leftist activists in the country
seem to think that joe biden can
absolutely be manipulated i'm thinking
of angela davis
an out-and-out a valid communist
who exploits the issue of race the power
of melanin
to quote nick cannon to push
an explicitly communist agenda
she thinks biden is easily manipulated
i don't see this election as being about
choosing a candidate who will be
who will be able to lead us in the right
direction
it will be about choosing a candidate
who can be
most effectively pressured into
allowing more space for the evolving
anti-racist
movement biden is far more likely to
take
mass demands seriously
he's he's much more likely to do that so
you've got to vote for joe biden because
he's a daughtering old man who is
politically
relatively weak and who is going to
listen to what the radicals want
and if you doubt angela davis because i
generally
doubt the things that communists tell me
though she has been prominent for many
years
take it from biden himself who just
recently quoted
chairman mao one of the most
blood-soaked communist dictators in
history
biden quoted mao he thought he was
quoting quote an old chinese proverb
and and the prophet is this biden said
according to news reports
women hold up half the sky so it's an
old chinese proverb
it's not that old it's a saying of mao
zedong
mao zedong said this because he wanted
to make the argument that women were an
important
labor resource and women needed to leave
the home
and shouldn't be homemakers anymore and
should go out and work in the fields
and work in industry and advance the
cultural leftist revolution so you got
the guy
already now promoting the explicit
sayings of communist dictators not
not a good position to be in even joe
biden who is
probably the most moderate guy left in
his party really is just an empty suit
who licks his finger puts it up in the
air and figures out which way the wind
blows
joe biden now is seating all that ground
to the radical left
and they're gonna they're going to
continue to exploit it time
and time again as we get closer to
november
and they'll use that fault line that
power of melanin that weak spot on race
but this is all about a radical ideology
and and when their efforts fail when
they fade away when the race riots ebb
and the people stop caring about the
lockdowns that are going to kill
2 million or 10 million people and the
predictions don't don't come true
they'll find some other crazy way to
distract you so much of this
seems to be about distractions burger
king
burger king is the latest company to get
really woke their new ad campaign
is not about how delicious their
hamburgers are the bigger the burger the
better the
burger's bigger at burger king no they
now the woke culture has gotten so
extreme
so absurd that their ad campaign is
about how they are
as a corporation reducing
bovine flatulence in the atmosphere
[Music]
methane every time they do
and that methane from the ring goes up
to the atmosphere
and pollutes
[Music]
[Music]
is it hot in here or is it just me so to
change their
missions burger king went on a mission
testing diets i would have produced
their farts
[Music]
[Music]
when i'm thinking of what to eat for
lunch or dinner
the image that i definitely don't want
in my mind
is cows passing gas
that doesn't that's not nice that
doesn't sound good and by the way
presumably they're talking about this
new grass that they have
that's going to reduce the amount of
times that cows do that presumably then
that that that air is going to be
trapped inside the cows and it's going
to end up in our hamburgers which is
even more disgusting
that doesn't sound very good advertising
used to talk
talk about how great their product was
make it so much more attractive
and yet now everything has become so
politicized the personal is the
political
everything i mean this this was the this
was the promise of the rise of identity
politics
that now we're all so obsessed with was
that when you're when you have a
separation between the public and the
private
the personal and the political that we
require in a democratic republic
then the conservatives are going to win
because we can have reasoned debate but
when you have identity politics
when you just talk when you talk about
the sun people in the ice people
you talk about how those people are less
than they're savage they're they're
like animals and we're like we're
civilized humans and that's it
based on our race when when you have
that then you're you you're a much more
reliable
voting block the personal is
everything's got to become political
now including cheap hamburgers when i
think of bovine flatulence it occurs to
me
maybe i've been wrong about this whole
mask thing maybe i've got to start
wearing face coverings that is by the
way the guidance now from the
cdc cdc director dr robert redfield
insisting that people wear
their face masks the face coverings work
it's our major defense to prevent
ourselves from getting this infection if
all of us would put on a face covering
now for the next four weeks
to six weeks i think we could drive this
epidemic to the ground in the country
oh that's all it takes we just
we just wear a mask for the next four to
six weeks
and then we can drive this epidemic to
the ground
really wish someone told me that 130
days ago
really wish someone told me that in
march actually do you know what they
were telling us in march when that when
the virus was exploding all around the
country
do you know what our public health
officials including the most prominent
one dr fauci was telling us
they were telling us not to wear the
masks
there's no reason to be walking around
with a mask
when you're in the middle of an outbreak
wearing a mask might make people
feel a little bit better and it might
even block
a droplet but it's not providing the
perfect protection that people
think that it is and often there are
unintended consequences people keep
fiddling with the mask and they keep
touching their face
so somebody made a giant blunder here it
would seem to me
either the guy who at the beginning of
this whole thing told us not to wear the
masks dr fauci
or the guy who's now saying we could
completely route the virus
if we wear masks for four weeks both of
whom are top public health officials in
the country
or they're lying or they're cynics or
they just in any case have no
credibility no credibility at all it is
not possible
to have a reasonable discussion about
this virus about this issue
because the experts that we're supposed
to be listening to
cannot be trusted because they have
changed their tune with political wins
and even if it weren't with political
wins even if they just were incompetent
and got it wrong
they got it wrong so spectacularly and
forget even just the masks they got it
wrong on the models they got it wrong
all over the place
they got it wrong so spectacularly we
cannot trust them
we can't we cannot have reasonable
dialogue
the new york times can't have reasonable
dialogue you and i
can't we're not allowed to have
reasonable dialogue we have to remain
distracted with stupid nonsense
like bovine flatulence
and like the sun people and the ice
people and the power of melanin
we have to be we have to be misdirected
with stupid nonsense like renaming the
washington redskins they're going to
rename they've talked about it for years
white liberals have threatened to do
this for years rename the washington
redskins
because white liberals are offended on
behalf of native americans washington
post put out a survey when this
first became a big issue a few years ago
they they surveyed a group of native
americans asked
how many of you are terribly offended by
the name washington redskins
and one it changed nine out of ten
didn't care nobody cares
ridiculous stupid nonsense meant to
divide us
meant to prevent
reasonable discourse meant to
keep us all ginned up in hysteria and
rage
so that we can't see what is happening
all around us the clear political
agendas
that are being advanced three more
months to the election folks
think we've got to get our heads out of
that place where the air is coming out
of the cows
i think we've got to stop talking about
the power of melanin
and start talking about the real
political power that we could exercise
if we could only understand the stakes
that's our show i'm michael knowles this
michael knowles show
get your mailbag questions in i'll see
you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy boary
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
technical producer
austin stevens assistant director pavel
wadowski
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva production assistant ryan
love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clayton